monsieur le ministre la parole et à
monsieur remis rémi delattre merci vous
plaît républicain merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
ne vous en déplaise votre politique
fiscale fait d'un matraquage permanent
et de rétropédalage récurrents n'apporte
aucun résultat tangible en matière de
croissance
pire elle ne réduit que de très peu les
inégalités entre nos concitoyens alors
que c'est votre montre à votre prétexte
pour assommer toujours plus les classes
moyennes tout cela nous vous le disons
depuis plus de trois ans et vous le
balayer d'un revers de main or
aujourd'hui c'est l'insee qui vient
confirmer ce constat d'une part les
hausses massives d'impôts que vous avez
décidé depuis 2012 plombe le niveau de
vie des ménages
en effet pour 4 8 millions de ménages
que vous présentez comme gagnant
ce sont 19 millions de foyers qui sont
perdants notre part votre politique dite
de justice fiscale ne fait plus illusion
hausse de l'impôt sur le revenu et des
cotisations retraite fiscalisation des
mutuelles et majoration de 10 % pour
charge des familles toutes ces attaques
contre le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
amplifie la colère sociale sans réduire
significativement l'écart de niveau de
vie entre nos compatriotes face à cela
vous avez toujours la même parade
l'héritage de vos prédécesseurs et bien
écoutez les paysages de la découverte en
plein débat budgétaire de milliers de
petits retraités soumis aux impôts
locaux en est le dernier exemple
la faute à l'ancienne majorité mais
monsieur le premier ministre qui selon
sinon vous à augmenter les impôts de 50
milliards d'euros depuis 2012
ces augmentations sont bien de votre
fait elles sont de votre responsabilité
monsieur le premier ministre les
français demande une chose simple
quand allez vous enfin avoir une vision
juste et cohérente de la politique
fiscale dans notre pays
merci monsieur delattre la parole est à
monsieur le secrétaire d'état chargé du
budget monsieur christian eckert
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
vous avez effectivement eu raison de
faire état de l'étude de l'insee qui a
été publié joie hier et dans la presse
se fait l'écho aujourd'hui nous n'avons
pas la même lecture
ça peut arriver mais moi j ai relevé un
certain nombre de points plutôt
réconfortant d'abord que les inégalités
se réduisent apparaît surprenant mais
revoyez les tableaux pardon les
infographies qui sont publiés elle fait
bien état d'une réduction des inégalités
deuxièmement elle fait la preuve que le
modèle social français nous a permis de
mieux résister que nos voisins européens
à la crise notamment dans la prise en
charge chaque seconde de dépenses et
regarder le passage puisque j'ai bien
étudié cette étude
regardez le passage sur le reste à
charge après des sur les questions des
frais de maladie et vous verrez que
c'est dans notre pays que ce reste à
charge non seulement est plus faible
qu'ailleurs mais qu'ils continuent à
diminuer
alors oui les questions peuvent se poser
sur les efforts qui ont pu être demandée
par les uns par les autres nous avons
souvent ce type de débat ce que
j'observe c'est que depuis deux ans déjà
nous sommes passés à une phase non pas
de stabilisation de l'impôt sur le
revenu mais de redistribution de l'impôt
sur le revenu puisque dès l'année
dernière est encore dans le projet de
loi de finances qui vient d'être adoptée
si en première partie à l'assemblée
nationale nous prévoyons des réductions
d'impôts alors sur
les questions concernant les impôts
locaux je rappelle quand il s'agit
d'impôts locaux ne dit pas d'impôts pour
l'état prend beaucoup de choses ont été
dites
il est temps aujourd'hui de reprendre
confiance je vous invite à regarder ce
que diront demain la commission et le
fmi qui sont de passage à paris
notamment sur la croissance dans notre
pays merci merci monsieur le ministre la
caisse la séance des questions au
gouvernement
et terminer la séance est suspendue